ciao ragazze benvenuti questo nuovissimo
anche oggi si parla di natale e brave
richieste in tantissimi questo video è
infatti ho deciso subito di farlo
parliamo di tipologie di ragazze a
natale sono sicura che tantissimi di voi
si ritroveranno una di queste tipologie
quindi fatemi sapere in quale di queste
tipologie di ritrovate in più e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutti carte
socia ci vediamo alla fine del video
ciao io adoro il natale lande i ricavi
da eni paolo trande le lucine il natale
fa schifo nella festa inutile fatto per
gente inutile ipocrita e soprattutto
finta che cosa hanno tutti a festeggiare
tutti esaltati balocchi gli alberi le
luci nei regali dolci che fanno vuole
ingrassare le fa schifo a bagheria
[Musica]
tesoro e mangel almeno un po di frittura
ma la frittura non la posso mangiare che
lo ha detto sulla dieta chieda chi è un
e non saggia un po di lasagna che ha
fatto mamma tu con le sue mani ma
ciabatti e ciao ciao vecchi e svagarsi
sport day è una mission merry christmas
suo ormai followers bevi rai o macgraw
wings of est e di firmare belli allora
zio luigi cosa posso regalare soldi di
ripulire gli occhiali lui portò gli
occhiali me ne farà sicuramente invece
alla zia rosa regaliamo quello che ho
già fatto l'anno scorso
perfetto poveri per utile vestiti
l'amerò
[Musica]
buon natale ma grazie a questo pacchetto
mi dispiace quasi aprirlo vabbè dai lo
apro piano così è mai visto un fiocco a
chi lo guarda che ci sono riuscita ma
non era questo gioco aspetta allora come
possiamo fare allora
strappa la carta ma il musico rino non
vogliono minarda magari poi si può anche
utilizzare basta non ce la faccio più
ricche nell'anima di morte spazio tavolo
c'è poi chi ci dissero dimettessero
sulle loro tavole diciamo di giocare mi
fate schifo pure ragione siete una
famiglia è arrivato berti stati periodo
natale ci sono ragazzi che già ci sono
arrivato un armadio ma non riusciamo a
capire cosa tutta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
buon natale mi chiedo allora ti piace sì
grazie
ti piace davvero sincera è ma eccoci
arrivati alla fine del video se vi è
piaciuto mi raccomando ricordatevi di
lasciarvi un bel live un bel commentino
ma soprattutto se non l'avete ancora
fatto iscrivetevi al canale
se volete sapere in quale di queste
tipologie mi ritrovo di più ricordatevi
di seguirmi su instagram perché me lo
dirò soltanto nelle di storie
vi ricordo che se non volete perdere
nemmeno un video pubblico su un canale
dovete assolutamente attivare le
notifiche e quindi cliccare la
campanella che trovate subito accanto al
tasso d'iscrizione
vi abbraccio fortissimo ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao
adoro
[Musica]